hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Brandi Frey
today we're checking out another video
from Conan um I'm mainly doing this for
me yeah people request these videos but
I'm like I I I'm putting these on the
top of my list because I [ __ ] love
Conan currently don't have cable um you
know I don't know many people with cable
these they actually don't have cable and
yeah everyone has like their Netflix and
[ __ ] but they don't have but I subscribe
to cook Team Coco yeah me too no me too
and so I figured uh yeah let's check out
another Conan video this one is Conan
give staff performance reviews
I love how interactive he is with his
staff you know yes he seems so friendly
and personal but I know he's tense if he
plays like the [ __ ] boss role a lot
you can tell like he he is like
personable with his staff his crew and
stuff as someone who runs a company I've
been told it is my job to occasionally
have performance reviews I've asked for
some assistance from my script
supervisor this is Danielle Weisberg
hello Danielle you are a script
supervisor and you not know what are you
monologue assistant
Oh what is script supervisor do that's
Susie who's Susie
ha
what is your main place Nega okay what
is your title in position mmm
photographer you're a photographer the
show needs a photographer yeah all right
you seem defensive are you a little bit
why because you're questioning my
position of the show maybe in no way do
I want you to feel nervous about this
this is just to decide whether or not
you should be fired
where's your life five seven five seven
what is your gender female hey I have to
fire three employees today it's just the
way it is this is the staff and crew of
Cohen would you please identify the
three people you think should go who's
that
totally crazy and it's always different
in the hall hey do you complain to me
about the way that I run the show rather
than for any personal quirks that I have
that make you uncomfortable
no I've been in the habit last few years
of walking up behind women and massaging
their shoulders the same daddy's home
inappropriate corner okay normally this
is the point where I would give you an
eight ten percent raise um not really
going to do that you are getting a great
job pin
and I'd like you to wear that here at
the show and at home
Manson Kramer you I know this is your
performance review and where's your
position here in show production step
production stuff what does that mean
describe what you do I do a lot of
things a lot of logistics I do love the
Warner Brothers lot I help with scouting
locations for releases me that when
someone says I do a lot of things it's
to cover the fact that they do very
little
I would disagree with that assessment
okay disagreeing with hosts of show
comes out working by but it's very much
unlike any other business environment
have you ever seen me do anything that
you thought was unprofessional squeaky
chair over there is that you Kramer
sorry
abused me however I used you what have I
done to you I really recently that was
choked I choked him you push me so what
do you think when I walk up to in the
hallway and I jump on you and start
choking you I think it's a release valve
and I think it's an actual release no no
now that you said Royce you it's a
really good body to sensual release
no but now that you're saying that now
I'm concerned and maybe it is okay is
that bother you is that okay that's how
I get my sexual thrills by choking it
doesn't bother me you're okay with it
bother other people you're okay with me
choking you if it gives me sexual
pleasure don't you say yes
what's it is fired do you think you're
strong enough to carry me out of this
building if I were unconscious I believe
I could get you up to go this is me I'm
choking you then smoke fills right the
room get me out get me out fast fast
what's your name please come a name is
Brad Brad I'm the photo researcher what
is a photo researcher do I find in
license all the switches that use on the
show let's say we needed a photo of Al
Roker how long would it take you to get
a photo of our broker like 20 seconds
maybe what about Al Roker wearing
pajamas okay not bad you didn't find our
real current pajamas but you did find
him in a gingerbread costume I've also
found al roker as mr. t there is as
Oprah and as Robin of Batman and Robin
what is your right 60 celebrity crush um
Margot Robbie the blonde and will get
Wall Street isn't credible right just
the bottom face yeah the bedroom with
yeah mystery but just use this backup I
need to fire three people please
identify the ones to fire jordan slant
see every place is taking this one yes
do you think you'd be able to carry me
out of this building I think so yeah say
so sack of potatoes over the shoulder
sure why potatoes cuz I'm Irish justice
anomaly 4/8 potato Sam Irish guy just a
bunch of potatoes right hopefully I
should do some taters sabotage this is
the Irishman that all I am to you know
okay I mean it could be stuck of
anything sack of [ __ ] maybe
really I mean [ __ ] is something so wait
we just caught me a side of [ __ ] to my
face what's your problem
do you want to be fired no I'm not gonna
fire you I'm not gonna fire you at all
you see here at Kona Co we believe that
everybody makes mistakes everybody has
those days this is um actually a song by
Hannah Montana Montana song chair yeah I
know
Kent I know you because I see you every
day you hold cue cards on the show
correct
you seem nervous oh no okay you also
seem you seem hi quite hi I'm not okay
yeah I'd like you to go through okay
take three people we should be fired
immediately can't even see right now or
is it okay yeah
hey guy do it on a full-blood sorghum
slansky fired unbelievable how many
years have you worked for me uh going on
like five and a half five and and have
you noticed me aging and the time I even
work no you look good you don't really
age that much sugar a young shape you
work out I do work out a lot but admit
it it's like watching a melon Robin the
song I made up just say it to say
sometimes I look at you and your melons
run it's okay to say that you can say it
say it
hey sometimes I look at you and your
face is getting really old and your
melons rotting
just say you look like a rotten own
what's the big deal just say I can't
just say it but wait let me looking
around knowing you look like a melon
you're fired
yes given that everybody without fail is
but I talked to today has said fire
jordan shlonsky i think it's fair for me
to ask you why are you crucial to the
functioning of Conoco go it's any
producer's job to make sure the hosts
like yourself is freed up to deal with
creative issues and doesn't have to get
bogged down in the mire of production
difficulties if I do my job well you'll
never know about it so when you're
performing at your highest capacity I
don't notice you without your saying
let's do it
but also if you weren't here and you
were doing nothing I wouldn't never see
so how do I know the difference between
you both feel the same correct
possibly Jordan I have decided not to
fire you congratulations in fact I'm so
taken with the general way in which you
conduct your life I decided to reward
you
I now would like you to take charge of
the common fire rescue dog just he can
handle it I'm training cardio pulmonary
resuscitation there's more life in his
eyes
we'll see
ah genius I love him I love him I want
to cuddle with Conan you would be the
small spoon for sure I'm right Connor in
a poem one day oh my gosh you should
write it right now I'm prompt to poem I
want to go a lot detail with it okay so
we don't want to go in I want to like
explore my feelings and see how I can
communicate that on paper I bet he could
write you an impromptu horn he can but
his would probably be funny I want mine
to be very heart out heartfelt and
serious very meaningful I want I don't
want people to laugh when they hear it I
want them to go wow I too wanna [ __ ]
Conan O'Brien like you're Ryan Gosling
poem well they're different you know
Conan's like Ryan Gosling's like you
know like sex candy and Conan's like
gingers that's a father figure you want
to [ __ ] oh
that is one of the most disturbing
things I've ever said in my entire life
I've said a lot of things but that was
like I wish I did utter those words but
if you guys are new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can check out Brandy's shut up it's a
good channel it's a good channel and Oh
brandy please tell them she's no I mean
let me try to tell them okay there's
gonna be an IndieGoGo campaign where
Brandy's playing together a short film
with a whole cast and crew and
everything called committed and guess
what it's about
Joker and Harley Quinn and guess who's
playing Harley Quinn well another cool
thing about it is that it's we're
donating to a thousand DVDs to operation
of comics relief oh nice so one of the
other cool things cherri
humble yeah dirty what charity is a
great thing operation comics relief is
awesome we're donating DVDs to soldiers
overseas why like why accept charity
like why it's like everyone should just
work for it what they are working for it
this is just kind of a fun comic really
well you know it's like you hear about
those third-world countries and it's
like you know if they just got a job all
their problems will go away and I could
make five cents an hour
exactly everyone's an idiot but me
you're right everyone's an idiot
I except for me and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
because if we get more followers we can
get more product placement